we have it Software Tales me I am live
i where am as usual to tell so give me a
quick message Ivan really live and you
yes God get good all your good video
quality all things
video quality just refreshing the page
might help okay but live gib  me
message yes thanks you alive i reading
dead in the chat I do Jack the chat and
the answer questions or requests
within reason inside to play
the score better
in my
enouncement on my channel I did not take
into account the daylight saving time
ink for get  that every year simply
because I think beer
whenever unlucky a few five minutes I
have not played the single game of chest
today in a Starling in the
okay Mister rustemorph strong player
this playing the Dutch so playing of bed
sightline I don't Wening age for g  -five
the wars
Player
telling him that age 6 is not great
which is problems not true okay weather
display normal developing moves and hope
that I'm okay um yes if you watch last
week and rating last week with I got
back to something better games
you in the last week
um yes people lake
problems YouTube
okay yes here is pending quite a lot of
time here and night
okay
okay now have question my familia
with the content of the sen Louis chest
Club on track yes please very nice very nice
very nice youtube  channel the videos are
almost all great the only want to stay
away from Miss Mike Kammer it's really
terrible dog
time
the line that I missed so I don't have
one okay going the seven
of
death okay so blackwind King to death
looks kind of  wrong
it's not easy to exploit
over take is 6
yes maybe I should cares along and lies
that's opposite the black King but it's
not that I can so easily pleutes
recky King Position here I really don't
see you
night be free
information at Mike  Chamber yes here is
the Queen scammed the small Exchange
Variation white which is no joke
to get the night to the four not so sure
it is so help for yes
now already like bad place for the night
run away okay
okay last down and try too  claim that
hitsship is badly place witches probly
true I can get to a form
Slot helping me that match Anakin take
before no I can action
and scary
okay he went back simply
back and going to easy
a bit
free and
thening on the age fahr i like  this time
pretty safe here I believe
baby it's too slow what I doing that's
really possible
Rook the just go be free
wanted night I too too required but keys
of course what for that
okay
okay strine2 muddy the water
y okay so night is reach form I have  to
Speeder
lands the five
not good not good at all
Check
oh Check
Noah come on that was bad here
even Ops
even and Ride before the end it was a
complete Wind for white of course
even around here hey was tricky I just
Dance Speeder better  problem I have to
really speed up at one Pointer was
behind on the clock okay next game
against Alexa here from Israel need to be
quicker
I did not see the Kings Game with game
from yvonnecuk
yeah sometimes places opening
it's not the one to
play the  sometimes
okay
position on this
is opening here the room inside
um okay
five i think i5 takes nightify
so let's do that I don't watch Game of
Thrones simply cannot watch that because
there is so many characters in the
strike nice
keep track of all the  people in this in
the show
yes you give lessons online
where you can send me messages and me
stuff on course
within huge
like
um
is not so easy to do that
simple questions
is
takes night be seven looks so no
yes required for isolated looking
the nights  and the Bischof so Promi it
was Nordbad
problem I don't know the position
tactical resource which is always thirty
possible
I like just space I just ahm
the company that you somethings that
don't like
ing special on the telling about
US
and the Clark  have here Just Dance the
simple question
this is kind of Tipico behavior list
and like that much okay here sacrificing
this
for the ship seven
yes not much
seven
i don't really have a sixes only singer
can do
if I don't lose one of  the okay but not
so easy
and
to get the deep on
F1
not falling into that
take this and no hope that
I'm not getting
t bei the Sporns
Note
and peace callination
and might be
boat pieces control F6 very good
I don't play  for win here
with looks Lux Whiskey
not
okay any style to in the game with
okay I couldn't really Rewe
the recent messages
it's that have to play the game
what do we have
Williams Killer French DVDs very good
entertainment and
you can you can really  use that also from
aggressive French Rapper nice
it sometimes bit on the Dyson side what
is ages but it's okay it
space it okay special leave your
don't faces super stronger Supermans
principles behind the Amadeus video on
that super
deep one
Adam hello
okay
with this  crazy counter with
are you doing
and time when I was winning that
I lost on time losing positions so
like simply simply
kundenfindered the Dutch landing read is
okay now will yes okay it's a bitter
risky
yes before lightsquare Rapid was in the
nimzo on I Recon man  take so move at
Move at John Hems this is this book
from think to town complete
Williams of course and interesting
out of Manchester
play the Nimo at adieuring is quite
good questions
yes always people have to be sing in the
historical context in disccase fishing
not super  far away for me old
timewise the
different time
is the wild comparison and be far away
from one another
here against the
whites Queen Set structure world
checking
a progress life much
and the form
is not a problem in might move to
fix and give me some is  your some my
King but I'm really lot on the clock
games and
lot of instructive games older games for
example I think I'm from the very old
stuff Rubinstein is very instructive
head the Toms of great games very
logical games that had Avery natural
floatem here is special League good
endgameplayer really remarkably good and
gameplayer
is one of the most instructive Player 2
move blocking in the rock
okay okay
yes Rubinstein is the absolute Endgame
the Rook and game Guru about
fantastic Rock endgameplayer really um
wait a minute doing here
quinci 54
yes yes
here everyone
find people
the match to finance the match and then
there was world one and that was
das du invent starting opening book
lines fun
I always enjoyed studying the openings
have to it with
to Explorer ideas that let you
interesting middle games and I  study
Quinn lot in that we got not so much
like
that
me the gaming media
yes was the world champion something in
different time
it was twenty seven years and different
and today it was training what can you
do okay that is an endgame when not
much is  happening on
from the
my bit bit
the line that you places something where
really don't have a good a don't really
have a good recipe against that I have to with
i wonder ifnight e too is an ID night E2
and Queen
i don  't know
no
takes
and five on the time
nice position
good I could go for me
from back yes a bit of sex
in I would very good plan baby
is none
do you really take my system
yes
historic oh as simply blonde the piece
oh wow that is  my he would have his you
your before is no blues so am going to
show you this is Outlander the peace
okay yes are you really taking my system
what what in this book is Nonsense in
what not because say the Lord of Nonsense
in this book der many interesting  points
with many things simply one and
strong player can filter
experience Player Nord
wrong I know right in this book in the
form
between so I was thinking that I can
play nightings if 54
let's do this move first think later
maybe in take with the night
but  it's cannot
we know what kind of book my system is
okay
now chest save Gina
players of course yes here are
F6
position here
so what you for right
here not really or age free
Armin her the hard time
will be a
deliver made on YouTube
these are look  bad
EAK
yes Evans Enterprise liver this is the
okay I am just gotion
oh this is the night dear I did not
really recognized
okay
here is Queen F7 so
or
okay so here I recognize rocks
and try to
infiltrate
it's not really netting me anything I
have to  with
equalish
before is the move
not Happing much
Ing
try maybe it
okay simply nothing
nice played and try have to try that
what I tried just the doing something
Norman with better
was kind of influence really by the
beginning of this game where was just
winning
and  try to do stuff thating
yes is most endgames here where
beatron
and a don't have don't have any time
in a small
special
queen situation
the band castles
back F8 this win with Rook A3
winning wasn't dreaming
okay so last
okay
questions
yes an Icon sittered doing in Amy from
me anything on reddit on simila with
didnot happen
the might be Intercity nice
so isticks and stupid the seven
as not so easy Baby
free so not good and
the Vienna Games alternative to the
Spanish I know
I Met Your  can play Orkans of openings
without being worse and probably except
the Vienna Armin recent Leader book
publish Standard
i don't really am I don't
and
people case for many openings and you
can trisings but doing
complex opening
work and long term it with payoff
okay so funny Position
development first and dance
it looks very nice but it's not so easy
to get something concrete down
GeForce
okay
yes
how to control nerfs again strong the
place hmm I don't really have a great
peace of advice for that
definitely get better  by the winnix
experience
I really don't have any grated white for
that I know that I was men plate my
first grandmaster and things like that
oh even back play the title players for
the first time and now days
like totally Norma
not happening that I really  don't in any
at the way that game
what this help sometimes if you can't
off nervous against higherated players
Assault
it happens to play play the man online
Blitz and see that they do made mistakes
evenive Blacks but that you make
mistakes stuff yes  day make the same
mistakes that everybody Max just not so
open
and them I think this is helping alone
it I think lots of confidence title
Player my beating them on the Assassin
for the longetank control Games
okay or strong but this so human the
under play
okay  Queen Beate for be 54
takes on Eve please 9
the good at classical time control games
but really terribles is the giant
had same in the
munching with chassis is um it's the
matter of practice practice practice and
you will eventually get better
or not
breathing problem
classical time  control is the one that
matters most
in West time to improve
over time if you are find
in London
when I visited recognizing that's
germanlement and chest Network no we
don't even communicate he is the not
universalon to messages so now
difficulting so um i don  't really mind
that
okay last what happens CIA can off
me six
don't know that this looks live i like
my position Lord
um hast
attack the deeporn
is that is long as a keep everything
together here are very hard time
to ever activate
to use now yeah
six coming
yes my envy here and die Free can I do
something what I can do with actually I
can take here and take on the
any problem with that I don't Seeed
i just wanna win this game that would be
nice  right
i would really like to win Agame once in
the war
oh interesting
is
the one I am checkmated
and he wants to play what exactor
I can takes See five
oh my God
Position
session and last week was really
terrible have to thing about this how do
I play better in the in the early
assessments like weeks ago I was playing
much better
time oh wow
really Kind
history here let me check this is cand
of inverything I lost single game right
wow
wait here no
live
it's none none that's
okay
for is good now
commands recognizes
why not be takes you going to trap me
your what night Teams Tick once to his
he is going to trap me
okay
that makes e for Kind
Position
yes Queen age 7 Voldemort Slip yes on the
queenaged Summer okay
now now  I'm just getting getting
nothing that I can do really
um yes night age 6
well okay okay
sorry
great it's um that's one of the
worst runs I really ever had and Blitz
okay
is not an okay
French opening player to look at some
instructive  Games yes mikragurovic and
drive very good French place
some specialist okay letssiever can do
something about one hundred rating
points in the session
playing agains tour to one eight 2
okay 5
and yes that is one of the the man lines
of this opening I don't  know it's all I
started to play this and
I'm always of making it up long is we go
ing to Triforce five
giving away A5 because of the night
takes the five idea okay Playstation
in the early again but
it didn't help very  much
okay
S i like to take with the night Team
five but this should give me quite Dean
Compilation if you really takes it
behind are
okay
new frenchbook
French some music
for French defense
okay so what is the second take better
have Queen this none  with you there is
still netting me that much
it is nice position now Bad
i don't see
much here
after this
baby just free and try need
one more
that one
oh wow
and
this one
of course Orchid
now we can at least draw with Queeny  one
Queeny one yes I
recognize
here
whiches
yes the Kenny player
okay he Laus me to do that
okay not winning that one I will quit i
want play Phone Player not a game
okay so E5 Rook TV takes on F6 so on
the has to move the night
Look the one in front of a taking F6
G6
is my better five I can easy take on
the song
so the dark Squash
my girl where
want to get the sky
and
really hopeless
so let's let's hope
i'm going to do it
See doing here night is free  are
something
okay
night A5 TX takes
y one queen E6
and
night sea free is no is he wants to
actually Miss places Queeny doesn't want
to defend it's very interesting
so here I can play night
where is the promo
okay
from Nike 5
Harry  was all that
you can I go every day
might be able to do that for Quinte 7
5 now I don't see you greath of the that '
s
seven
this porn on TV
auf der IT minutes almost in the
streaming for my first win Baby
with feels like and don't do Valle at
this time and what the says because I
really plate much better in early
streams
so night fix and winning the Queen but
it's not the clear business
of materials
uh yes so
down the age for with well
Eski  God here is right now Rookie
dance
here Street pieces creepeace for the
Queen
in fear everything is on course
even night defive might be my be
possible
yes
night five I probably have to sacrifice
the exchange then
you know nothing else
I can't even play Rookie 79
okay
yes  here is are very very well here in
this position
Queens a pretty good in Blitz Jazz of
coursed this is not wanna los cases
night Edge forest coming
anyway to Penn am with the Wonder
something
about that
my
oh last Preising
that
this
okay so a bit that
's mine
simply because of the tonights that
cannot be made but the position
which was really Terrorfilm what
can I do I lost one hundred twenty
points in the session this is really
great yes
one and more
playing the blitzking of all people the
Blitz King
okay
um Training really heart
at seven and here baby baby is no
air in Endgame me take
it's not supersolid after mit but at
least i'm not going to get Check mated
quickly hope
have to be mode in your in your IDs
after this run but the trend to lose
material
itstarts
7 is how to defend
attack on the
bed runner
ner action
game of chess Haven Wanne game of chest
today not a single one as started play
exactor session and play any Blitz game
of whatever
games
at least positions
the last one was really really really
bad frame and I managed to school that
one up
and Rosin easy actually
okay so and at least it's a pretty
standard simple looking and game here
and the blitzking is more the morning
rampant Player so am kind of
okay with this moment
an here
baby just this I  can do you this
not helping much
and at least look like I'm going to
blonders
okay whatever can take be six you is
really not going anywhere
so you giving
okay
this porn
okay Armin
okay
so now not Happing me that much this
and go from
the  going to do what exactly
Rookie five yes
so now
position
really not on
so lever out of me to take that
okay
maybe something better even
yes is
on the 14th
and this is my first win thanks thanks
starts against my first win of this bloody
session
okay spirit
and
look at you get my history here